[تصفيق]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
المهم مشون المنسيون
المهمشون
المنسيون يمشي الفقير وكل شيء ضده والناس
تغلق دونه ابوابها هذا يعيبه وهذا يهينه
ويرى العداوه ولا يرى اسبابها هذا هو حال
فئه المهمشين في المجتمع فمن هم المهمشون
المهمشون شريحه اجتماعيه ضعيفه من ذوي
البشره السوداء او السمراء ينحذرون من
اصول افريقيه لكنهم قطعوا صلتهم بوطنهم
منذ عصور طويله فصاروا مواطنين يمنيين
اصليين يستحقون حقوق المواطنه المتساويه
المواطنه اللي مش الورق ولكن المواطنه
اللي على ارض الواقع
ماذا يقولون عنهم
يقولون عنهم انهم اشخاص
مسؤولين عن الظروف التي يعيشونها نتيجه
لضعف الوازع الديني وغياب المبادئ
الاخلاقيه
يقولون عنهم
انهم ياكلون لحوم موتهم
ولا يدفنون موتهم في مقابر المسلمين
وانهم بلاطجه
وا
باحي وخطر على امن المج
تمع يقولون عنهم لا
[موسيقى]
لا تتزوجون منهم ولا تعاشرونهم ولا
تاكلونهم ثقافه مجتمعيه موروثه تكرس
المزيد من التمييز والكراهيه
ضد هذه الفئه المسحوقه
قال تعالى
يا ايها الذين امنوا لا يسخر قوما من قوم
عسى ان يكونوا خيرا منهم ولا نساء من نساء
عسى ان يكون خير منهم ولا تلمزوا انفسكم
ولا تنابزوا بالالقاب
وقال تعالى ايضا يا ايها الناس ان خلقناكم
من ذكر وانثى
وجعلناكم شعوبا وقبائل
لتعارفوا ان اكرمكم عند الله اتقاكم ان
الله عليم خبير
والتعارف في نص هذه الايه الكريمه يعني
التعايش التعايش الذي يحدث بين الناس من
خلال التزاوج
والمعاملات والهجرات المتبادله
ماذا يعاني المهم
يعاني المهمشون من حاله حرمان شديد
يعاني المهمشون من حاله حرمان شديد وفقر
وعده مشكلات
اضعفت لديهم القدره على الاندماج والتعايش
في المجتمع من بين تلك المشكلات
تمييز
والاستبعاد والظلم الاجتماعي
ومن مظاهر هذا التمييز والاستبعاد والظلم
الاجتماعي انه تمثيل المهمشين بممثل واحد
في مؤتمر الحوار الوطني الشامل ممثل واحد
وهم حوالي ثلاثه ونصف مليون نسمه من تعداد
سكان اليمن
انتشار الفقر
وضعف مستوى دخل الاسره المهم مشى مما يجعل
ارباب الاسر اكثر عرضه للاضطرابات النفسيه
ارتفاع نسبه الاميه
وضعف مستوى التعليم
والوعي الثقافي
مما يجعل افراد هذه الفئه اكثر عرضه
للانتهاكات الحقوقيه
كثير من الاطفال
المهمشين لا تتوفر لديهم شهادات ميلاد
ويعانون من التنمر الاجتماعي في المدارس
مما يجعلهم اكثر عرضه للتسرب المدرسي وعمل
الاطفال
كثير من الشباب المهمشين لا تتوفر لديهم
بطاقات اثبات هويه شخصيه
مما يجعل هؤلاء الشباب
اكثر عرضه
للبطاله
والشبهات
والانحرافات السلوكيه
كثير من الاسر المهمسه تعرضت للتهجير
القسري وهذا حدث في عدن
والمكلا وابين والضلع وتعز والحزيزه عمال
النظافه والصرف
من افراد هذه الفئه المهمشه يعملون في
ظروف عمل رديئه جدا
مما يجعلهم اكثر عرضه للمخاطر
المهنيه كما انهم يستلمون رواتب ضئيله
وبشكل غير رسمي
بشكل عام
الفعل مهمشه تعيش في بيئه مليئه
بالقاذورات
مما يجعل افراد هذه الفئه اكثر عرضه
للامراض والاوبئه
حوالي 500 فرد
من افراد الفئه المهمسه ينزحون تحت
العبوديه طبعا هذا وين يحدث هذا يحدث في
حجه
والحديده يعني في المناطق القريبه من شمال
من
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
طبعا
استشعار المني
بالمسؤوليه تجاه افراد هذه الفئه
التي لا يكاد
انسيه لا يسمع لها كلام ولا تشارك مشاركه
فعاله في الحياه السياسيه والعامه وفي
اتخاذ القرارات
طبعا بصفته
ناشطا
واجتماعيا وبصفه احد افراد هذه الفئه واحد
قياداتها المجتمعيه
سهم
انا ومجموعه من افراد الفئه الفاعلين
مجتمعيا
في
تاسيس
اتحاد المهمشين في اليمن عام 2007
وتاسيس جمعيه الشباب
والاحياء الشعبيه في عام 2009
ساهمنا في نشر التوعيه الحقوقيه وفي حل
النزاعات التي تحدث بين الافراد المهمشين
وبين الافراد المهمشين وافراد المجتمع
الاخرى ساهمنا في مناصره حقوق هذه الفئه
من خلال وسائل الاعلام المختلفه
ايضا في حل مشكلات الخدمات
الاساسيه يعني مستوى الخدمات الاساسيه في
المناطق المهمشه مستني جدا ايضا
عملنا على دعم الشباب
رياضيا
وثقافيه شباب الفئه المهم في المناطق
الفعل يعني بالنسبه لي انا اتكلم تحديدا
على يعني منطقه منطقه عدن
طبعا
كل تلك المساهمات المستوى الرابع جدا
ايضا ساهمت في
تحريك مجتمع المهمشين
ويعني التعبير الظاهري المهمشون عندهم
قنفره على التعبير الظاهري حول يعني
حقوقهم
المسلوبه كان اول ما حد يقدر يقول له يا
خادم
الان ما تقدر انت تعمل كذا ايضا حفز كثير
من شبابنا الفعل للفعل انهم يؤسسوا يعني
جمعيات ياسسوا مبادرات
شاركت في في تفعيل مجتمع المهمشين
العلاقات بين الشباب المهمشين وشباب
المناطق الاخرى تحسنت بعد ان كانوا يعني
في نزاعات فيما بينهم
وحدثت عندنا كثير من المشاكل وتدخلنا نحن
ايضا في حل في حل المشكلات
والنزاعات ما بين
الشباب المهمشين وشباب الان الحمد لله
تعال عندنا في السيله في الشيخ في
المحاريق في الشرقيه تلقيهم ان شاء الله
كلهم يلعبوا
من ابيان من اي مكان حيلعبوا
الم
يحن بعد
من صنع القرار السياسي ان يسنوا
قانونا يجرب التمييز ويعاقب عليه
وان يضعوا استراتيجيه ادماج
للمهمشين حتى يستفيدوا من طاقه المهمشين
المعصره يعني تخيلوا كم نسبه الشباب
المهمشين
طاقه معطره يعني ما حد يستفيد منها في
عمليه الانتاج في عمليه يعني تنميه
المجتمع طيب
الم يحن
نحن
وانتم
ان نعيش في محبه ووئام واخاء
وسلام لنبني مجتمعا مدنيا
عاجلا
قويا
قادرا ان يتسع للجميع
يقولون
ان لون الليل اسود
لكن لونا ليل انا بكل الالوان شكرا
لاسرائكم حفظكم الله والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[تصفيق]